assalamualaikum did you know that Jesus
was a Muslim
I'm with dr. marijuana how are you she
said I want to come look like a hundred
I mean now you actually are responsible
you're in the organization ask if you
have any questions any doubts even you
want to know how is Jesus of Muslim go
to ask a Muslim calm and did you get a
lot of response from the billboards that
you guys did oh oh definitely we had the
at one point we even had a demonstration
and in front of the billboard and we had
thousands of emails people asking us you
know what was Jesus a Muslim a lot of
them unfortunately thought thought of it
as an insult but they did not that this
is a core belief within Islam initiative
in which that part of our beliefs six
article belief is that we believe that
prophet the prophets we live other plans
as well as hanataro we live in Abraham
Moses Jesus and all of them Muslim all
of them submitted to God Allah Subhanahu
WA Ta'ala that's real simple because
someone says well how would Jesus a
Muslim well did Jesus submit to God or
himself he submitted to who to God -
Allah - the Creator very simple to
review and he and that was that was
actually mentioned in the Bible and
several times when she said in which
Jesus beside him said in the book of
John that I'm not following my well but
sure well and even in the book of
Matthew and all of us know that in the
2639 the famous verse where Jesus peace
be upon him took a step further and felt
and he put his forehead up in the ground
and he was he was shipping what you're
chipping himself or God Almighty the the
verse that comes to my mind that is so
powerful it's like the testimony of
faith when someone becomes a Muslim I
believe is John 17:3 where Jesus peace
be upon him who we love you can't be a
Muslim unless you love Jesus as a mighty
messenger and not God or a literal son
of God nowhere did he ever
copy of worship himself as a God but he
called people to worship guy he said
this is life eternal that you may know
the only true God and Jesus who was sent
by God that's it uh Sheikh how was the
you did we just ran
I want no steps out there beautiful how
do you feel huh have a good workout it's
a good workout we encourage people to
come here because part of being a good
Muslim is you have to have a good help
Alice part I'll have given us this body
as anumana as a trust for us to have to
be to have to be healthy and share all
the time
how can people law if they want to know
more ask a Muslim can ask lossless
you're good you can ask you questions
about Islam and we have a last chat
there if you have any questions ask o
Muslim thank you Salam alaikum peace be
with you smell now people wonder what is
the status of Jesus peace be upon him in
Islam do Muslims respect him do they
honor him is he a prophet or is he God
according to Islam first all Muslims
consider Jesus peace be upon him is a
Muslim do you know that the word Muslim
mean the one who submit to God's will to
Muslims the word Muslim is an honorary
title to those who completely surrender
themselves to God's well for instance in
the quran surah 37 103 allaha note Allah
says Phelim [ __ ] or teleology beam
when are they never a year brahim in
translation when Abraham and Ishmael
completely surrendered themselves and
they became Muslim and they followed the
orders of God on the sacrifice so
therefore it was an honorary title
forever ahem to be called a Muslim when
he completely surrendered himself to
God's well do you know that according to
Muslims all prophets of God were Muslims
and all of them carried the same message
in which they were calling people to
submit to God's will according to Islam
God hath sent approximately about a
hundred and twenty four thousand
prophets to this world in the Quran God
have mentioned only twenty-five of all
these prophets and out of those 25
prophets God have chose five to be
called allele azzam the best prophets
are only one prophet of those five
prophets God have called him the Messiah
which was Jesus peace be upon him do you
know that a Muslim cannot say the word
Jesus by itself and he have to say peace
be upon him as a form of respect do you
know that Muslims cannot and will not
represent an image of Jesus peace be
upon him because no one can replace his
image again this is the way we
honor Jesus peace be upon him how many
time have you seen Jesus based upon him
being represented in a cartoon or an
image in any Muslim country you will
never why because this is considered to
be a great disrespect and actually is a
blasphemy according to Muslims to
represent Jesus based upon him in a form
of an image in the contrary you will see
this being done so many times in the
West did you know that part of being a
Muslim that we have to believe in Jesus
peace be upon him and a Muslim is not a
Muslim who does not believe in Jesus do
you know that God had mentioned Jesus
this way upon him in the Quran 25 times
verses he only mentioned Muhammad we
step on him only five times do you know
that the most honorable woman in Islam
was Mary the mother of Jesus peace be
upon him do you know that Mary was
mentioned in the Bible only eighteen
times and in the Quran she was mentioned
thirty-two times almost 100 percent more
do you know that in the Quran God have
dedicated a whole chapter for the mother
of Jesus Surat Maryam or chapter of Mary
also do you know that God have dedicated
a whole chapter in the Quran to talk
about the Last Supper sure he'll Merida
do you know that the most number of
people named Jesus worldwide were
Muslims this is Jesus peace be upon him
in Islam we honor him we respect him he
is our role model if you have questions
about Islam do yourself a favor and ask
a Muslim